okay hi everyone starting a little bit
late here we are doing a welcome
language design review part of our
incremental language development
uh
series
so let's see what's first on the list
here this similarity measures yeah so
this is rounding out the the first set
of uh suggested functions from our chat
gbt plugin
um specifically it was trying to use
jarrow Winkler distance which we don't
have a system as is have as a system
function but it turns out we've actually
had it as an experimental context since
about 2008 it was added with some of the
other disability dissimilarity measures
and as far as I've been able to dig up
talking to to when and Rob it just was
never documented so it was never
promoted
um there's two very similar measures
gero distance and jarrow Winkler they
basically just differ in how they handle
a prefix scale
okay but they typically named separately
like that yeah so jarrow wingler is
basically a special version of gero
distance that gives extra waiting for
similarities at the beginning of a
string or a vector so I mean if these
are both widely used in literature I
don't see any reason you shouldn't have
them yeah I think it basically was just
something that uh never got documented
and then got put on the back shelf
um but I think it you know looks like
it's reasonably well used in literature
I don't know Michael if you have any
additional comments there but I think
it's basically just something we should
document and put no no the next build on
this
okay okay but now Roger was the person
who was in charge of these originally
and I've no idea why we stopped maybe we
have notes for why we stopped at this
point
yeah I mean I went back and talked to to
Gwen and Rob who'd originally put this
in and they you know it's been 15 years
since it was originally implemented so
they don't have thorough notes but I did
not specifically check with Roger when
did you say this was done this was added
in 2008 original for God's sake okay all
right oh yeah let's just put it in yep
that's basically what I figured but no
one seemed to know why we shouldn't so
okay take before and after
[Music]
so these are two related wfr functions
that are fairly popular
um effectively figuring out a
position of a given element and then
extracting either the following or
preceding elements
right so this is kind of like
I mean
the thing that I'm a little bit confused
by so take off to could have a you know
like that third element there this could
be
let's say uh you know minus two to two
am I right
yes
there's a question about how to handle
zero
I think this is a situation where any
span like must not a span but a range
like this should include zero
I see but so this would be
because we haven't really had take specs
that are anchored to something like this
before right we've always had tech specs
that go with respect to the beginning of
the string or end of the string I think
the exception would be next prime
something like that and how does that
work
you know if memory serves and and this
source of some acrimony at one time but
I believe we include zero
so if I say next prime of did you see
that documentation
what did it say go back to it
next prime is no also known as previous
Prime details
oh that's crazy
that's crazy yeah I hope I didn't write
it no Roger wrote that that is clearly a
Roger note
haste error yeah so I I no I don't think
so I think he's
but he's trying to make the point that
you can also use it to get the previous
Prime yeah so that needs to say oh okay
sure sure
but it needs to say explicitly with
negative K it does this this is another
bad documentation
yep I will follow up okay needs to get
fixed but but this here minus two to two
I don't understand that I don't
understand that so what what's the so
then what is the zero I mean that is not
a span that's just that's just
listability oh
yeah yeah yeah right because zero would
make sense unless unless that happened
to be a prime right so we could see what
happens if you did 23 and zero
um
yeah if you do 23 and zero to give back
23.
does it
should
and it's
which you know makes a certain amount of
sense
uh Nick you use for some reason you're
you're writing on my screen I don't
think you want to be doing that I don't
want to be doing that sorry about that
the
okay so in this case here
how do we get the span
the before after span
didn't understand what I'm saying
including b or not including B
I'm happy to include B I think with
range negative two to two
how can that possibly work well okay
let's try it
I mean let's say see here
it doesn't like it it doesn't like it
but I'm not even sure that take after it
from a design point of view we could
make it like it
right I mean shouldn't the shouldn't
follow the president take not an X Prime
minus two two is the span it's not a
list of indices but it will be the wrong
span because minus two means from the
end of the list doesn't it isn't the
right span yeah it would mean before
that that right I mean you think her
Point whatever you want to call B
right but you can't do but the point Bob
the point that we're making is that you
can't take a span from minus two to two
that would be an empty span you can do
the span from two to minus two
right which is not the span you want
here
because those positions are relative to
the Anchor expression rather than
the beginning maybe we want an explicit
list
and listability
foreign there
and have it be but it could be a such a
list sure but I mean this is a relative
part specification which we've never had
before
right that's a new idea
and if we're gonna have relative Parts
specifications where else could we have
them
well again X Prime
yeah okay but I mean this is like for
example we could say
and I don't even understand if there are
three b's on the list which one are we
talking about here
right that's the other that's the design
question I have at the bottom of what do
you do for repeated elements I presume
you do the first one yeah I think that's
what it currently does the the wfl
version but I mean you might want
different Behavior whether it's take
after or take before
yeah
right so take it take before does the
first one take after does the last one
yes
unless we want some additional argument
that is the nth instance of expert
the current implementation of this the
fourth argument is a level spec another
another issue is are we assuming that
the list is sorted if not
then you know no no absolutely not why
why would we make such an assumption I
I'm I I understand we we don't want to
therefore
you know it
it gets a little weird
what gets weird well suppose we say
negative two comma two
are we anchoring this because it's take
after are we anchoring it to the last
occurrence of B
um Brazil well sure but
why what what why does the Sorting of
the list have anything to do with that
it it it doesn't it's it's the question
I'm asking is how are we interpreting
like for
minus two to two take after anchors
at the last occurrence of B and take
before anchors at the first is that
correct is that what we want that that
is the proposal I don't know okay
current functions too okay let's talk
about some use cases for this thing okay
for example
we might want to take the things around
missing
and I kind of feel like the thing we're
going to want
and maybe this is kind of crazy and you
know it's more like
given the five missings
in this list give me the little kernel
around each missing
so I'm saying what are the flanking
things of a given
element
more so than this particular thing where
we're just asking you know here it's
okay the thing hit zero or something
show me what happened next
you know for every zero I mean it's more
likely to be for every zero I want to
see what was around that zero
am I making sense
yeah I guess the the use of these things
we could have three functions right that
take before I take after and I take a
round
yeah but what's being the most partake
around is then
take around all of them
I'm sorry take around what
what you're proposing for a take around
what each eye is calling to take around
would be taking the surrounding on all
occurrences
hmm
yeah yeah I understand but I think
that's going to be the useful thing
anyway I think like select or any of
these things there is a case where
there's a single argument one
um
the uh versions of these would be really
useful too which ones string versions of
these functions yeah
context for it
yeah
right for a particular word
but I mean that that is that's more like
text
words around
except I don't really like using the
term around because we've used a round
for on you know numbers with uncertainty
it's a different thing
um
neighbors or neighboring
it's a bit uh
take neighboring adjacent
and I like it Jason
take nearby
maybe take window
what else is a synonym for that kind of
thing
you can take before after
joining
um
it takes
that's gonna say something stupid I know
it's going to say something stupid that
takes elements
around a specified element
in a list
oh come on
well you use the word element twice it's
gonna give it back to you
what did it do here element equals four
okay that was that was I mean I'm
impressed that it managed to write it
is it correct
this is becoming a lot like moving map
yes which is a window type thing which
was under attack thing yeah
yeah
um yeah I mean right it's a very naive
version of the function but it's not
right right it's like my moving map of
identity without
moving
well except it's not identity it's it's
only in particular places
yeah yeah I'm just thinking like the
window sort of
feeling to it yes
Sandra live stream is suggesting take
vicinity I think vicinity is a very take
um
uh let's see
uh
uh let me see
um well okay but let's imagine that we
have this thing whatever it's called
um
take margins
take Zone
what about taking neighborhood
I think that's weird because it's not
clear whether
take proximate
it's very weird
um
we had take adjacent which I think maybe
making looking better
I mean we've got other functions that
are like Split For example which is you
know
an adjacency story
uh all right so
let's say we're using take adjacent here
let's look at what it does
so let's say a list an element
and
see the problem is what we would like it
to return here is probably the before
after
before element after
which kind of makes it seem like take
window is not the worst name
because if what it was was take window
element comma
k
then that's saying find the K elements
before you know find elements find a
window that is K before the element K
after
and then radius what's that that could
also be a radius specification yeah
that's but well what I'm suggesting is
it's like in cellular automata where the
R value is the distance before after to
go so the full is two R plus one
oh right yeah and and maybe like I think
I think we do this in cellular automata
we have you know and we certainly do
that in in Partition we have K left K
right whoops k l k r
right which is then then that allows one
to give a window
where
it's uh you know the elements before the
elements after
I think this is not completely silly if
this is what we're trying to do so then
but then it's going to have to have
oh boy I mean really it's take Windows
right because it's actually going to
have to be a list of lists
am I making sense because there's no
guarantee there's a single element like
that
and
am I making sense yeah and if you do
only want one maybe there could be a
fourth argument that specifies how many
yeah
yeah right
but now there's also the question of
what happens at the end
and I think it has to work the same by
default I mean you know it's either
going to have a padding set up like
partition
hey that reminds me something I would
like to do with Partition and this may
be more of an LCC thing just like in
cellular automaton we now have this
named Association way of setting up uh
cellular automaton I think we should do
the same thing with Partition
you know what I'm saying for the cases
what you don't want to remember the
order of all 9 000 arguments of
partition
uh that's what I'm saying yes
yeah it compete with list involved
in place with what list convolved
yes but what I'm saying is this is see
this form here right this is an
alternative rule spec
uh
this one here
okay which I really like I mean I I use
this quite a bit and I think we should
support us the same kind of thing for
for partition
as an alternative syntax you see what
I'm saying
let's try to make a design of this kind
okay well we where we talk about uh
you know I think we have in the
partition documentation we certainly
have names for all those pieces
do you see what I'm saying
mm-hmm
and we can have a named you know a
string name for the salon overhangs etc
etc
cyclic Etc
can you guys make up make a candidate
design for this please I think the I
mean I think the the first question we
should answer is
would this replace all arguments after
the first or do we want like
the first two arguments and then an
association I think we should allow the
possibility that you can go I think the
way it should work is
um
it should be partition you know in other
words if you know
okay partition
you know list
uh and
you know s or whatever you call it D or
whatever that's reasonably rememberable
but I think if you start off and you say
I mean this is not ambiguous syntax if
you say partition
and then you've got list and then you
start giving an association
then go for it
in other words I don't see why we
shouldn't allow an association at any
stage in the sequence
that is a
considerable departure
well the the padding
right the padding can be an arbitrary
element so which one is the padding
uh that is
um none of us know
oh maybe that oh I guess that's the last
one so I guess it's
uh
um
look I think if you're going to use an
association you will have used it by the
fourth argument
right
and I think
um
right so look let's study this is not
for for right now okay what we're
looking at right now here is take
Windows or take window I don't know
which is the right thing
um
that uh and what should it do at the end
in chat
for this span case
I'll put up
okay
yeah but I mean that it's not going to
work if they're two sevens in the list
right
right I just did first position you
couldn't make it
something
like Danny was saying we're
and you have to have some real some
default rule yeah but I think the
default should be all of them
I think that's going to be the most
useful
yeah it certainly aligns it with cases
and other
things like that if it's defaulting to
all of them
I just
think I'm gonna be using this first at
take window 95 of the time I use it
yeah I know
I know that's an annoying feature of
these functions that have
but you see you don't know in advance
how many they're going to be coming back
right
yeah and also it's not even obvious that
take is the right story here anymore
but this is really finding
you know Windows around
it's really more like cases window
or window yeah cases window and you want
it to be an arbitrary pattern do pattern
matching stuff sure why not exact value
yeah why not
so in other words this is
you know this is something which
essentially reaches it's like cases
but it's kind of reaching around
I mean and then then we could do you
know unfortunately I think string cases
window is less and less interesting than
uh
some kind of text
you know it's it's more like text words
windows so to speak
do you see what I'm saying
yeah
because that's what um
right which doesn't necessarily have to
be words
can be sentences or paragraphs or
anything
yeah
well I mean so text cases window
is a little weird
but I mean to me cases window seems the
most promising thing so in other words
it's like cases
but it returns a window but I don't
understand what it is at the end it's
definitely like a different
approach to like what pattern sequence
lets you do
um yes yeah
yeah right but I mean patent sequence
it's an outer approach instead of an
inner approach to the same problem
right
it cases with a rule second argument
could be adapted for this
um blank comma pattern comma blank
goes to
a blank comma pattern comma B blanket
what are you saying you're saying cases
what are you saying
so
um not for string cases I guess but
cases where well
just say what you were saying yeah I
guess it's akin to what you have there
with the repeated
only supplying a rule so that what you
return are are the things surrounding
pattern
I I'm I'm totally confused the second
argument I'm the second argument to
cases can be a rule
that's useful
especially if that could be a whole
I mean I can imagine
you know you want to find flanking
sequences basically
genetic sequence or something
potentially yeah
I think Danny's arguing you can do
basically the same version of this
Sans string by just using but by the way
I don't understand why this isn't a bug
because a
there are four A's in here why did it
only no they're five A's why did it only
pick three of them well I think because
there would be overlaps in some of them
and I didn't specify the option in
string cases for it
okay
okay makes sense
uh
sorry what were you gonna say somebody
else was saying something
I I was saying Danny was basically
arguing you can do the same thing with
cases
um
which is true you could basically yeah
yeah
that's the name for the function I
I'm sorry I was just thinking what about
flanking as the name for the function
Maybe
wanking cases
something
what happens if I go three away from
this
okay just it just ignores in this case
it just ignores
the one at the beginning that doesn't
have enough flanking
yeah so that the problem with flanking
is that the flanking is the is the flank
it is not
the
core of the animal if you understand
what I mean
yeah right and this includes the core
you know the anchoring elements
go ahead what were you saying
well I mean okay I think this is a
somewhat interesting function and I
think
that
um
windowed cases or something
yeah I mean in a sense it's more like
cases window because it Returns the
window
if you understand what I'm saying yeah
it's an evocative function name it's not
super Snappy
um maybe that's fine but plus window
cases is it has a different meaning in
the world
um what do you mean window cases like
casements or the yeah exactly right yeah
yeah
we have other functions that have window
in right mature yeah time series window
[Music]
my God
we have window frame
that's completely different window right
that's the reason to not use window
although it's used in plenty of these
other ones here
looks like
uh no that's not true
everywhere where it's a prefix it means
like a notebook on the screen
yeah yeah we can't use it as prefix here
right
but in these cases it means a statement
of a window
as opposed to like like this would mean
the DAP up Windows like the only one
wears out no no no look look these
things here mean this is a symbolic
representation of a window in a Time
series yeah right which is not what this
is doing this is returning
something
you see what I'm saying
so it's a different thing
uh
I mean and it's too confusing to call it
something like cases sequence because
we've already got sequence cases
and it isn't a sequence anyway
well okay we made some progress here let
us ponder that can you guys Ponder this
a little bit further and look at the
string and word cases
let's go from there yeah
key sort like
so this is a a bob function
um but the idea is that you have an
association and you're giving basically
a list of elements that specify a custom
sorting order
right I understand
why
I mean if you were to give a pattern
I mean there's this kind of A Sort like
uh
what am I trying to say
um
there's no point in saying sort light
because you're going to give how it
sorts and you might as well just give
that as the result the only case that's
interesting is when you're doing
I mean in the case of a list you can
specify permutation
in the case of an association I don't
really understand why
I think the main thing about this is you
don't have to specify all the keys right
so that you're just giving priority keys
that you always want to come first in
that order and then you don't care about
the rest right mine allows allows data
to not be in the rubric and it allows
values in the rubric to not be in the
data so
you know anything that isn't matching
just goes to the end and the preserved
order that came in
okay but so this works right now
right so really what the issue is I mean
so why isn't this then like sort like as
well
oh I have a function start like in a
function repository as well
it's just basically prioritizes certain
things exactly
and then the rest is sort left to sort
as it sorts but I mean in this case if I
take this thing here and I say key sort
of this I'll just get that
and I could equally well say key sort by
and if I had a predicate
here right I might even implement it
that way where I I just
thread the values in the thing with
range of length I think that might be
how it's implemented
um
okay
well I'm still trying to understand I
mean we we've we've been interested for
a while in these kind of templated
specifications of code and other things
which
I don't give me a use case for this
this is really useful for anything that
has like metadata right but so like
resource object metadata or like a
packlet info file things like that
you might want to always show the name
and description first and then I said
the rest of the data however it appeared
yeah when the data is ragged or
extensible so you don't know the keys
are always consistent right but this is
this is like show some stuff and then
there's a tail right
okay
all right so
this could perfectly well be
I see key sort like and then sort like
well it doesn't seem crazy
so then the idea would be
if it's there
sort the things which are matching
the things in that third element
sort those things in that order so I
could perfectly well say something like
if I said sort like
of
underscore integer underscore real
it would potentially sort all the
integers before the reels
Oops I meant sort like
does that make sense preserving
preserving the pre-existing order where
possible all the that's correct that's
correct so I mean it would just slide
the integer collection down in front of
the real collection in front of
everything else
yeah it makes sense yeah and so then the
default would be this comma blank
and it would be it would try to match
the first element first it would take
all of those guys to come in front take
the next ones
Etc until it gets to the the trailing
ones at the back which it just leaves
at the end
right so whatever order you give it is a
precedence order right that selling
blank is a fine mental model for how it
works yeah
what happens if you put something in the
sort like in the second one where it's
not in the list like if there's not that
key just ignores it okay
just like it would for a pattern if
there's no if nothing matches the
pattern it just ignores it
does keyshot like currently accept
patterns or are we just no I don't think
it does
working why would it accept patents I
don't think it has I don't we have a key
sort by which is a predicate based one
but I don't think we have a pattern
based one
okay because because it'll have a sort
Criterion that is a um you know an
ordinal sort function right
the comparator
like sort does sure I I'm just saying
you know you're proposed what I think
you're saying is you're proposing having
a key sort like and a sort like and I'm
commenting on the difference between one
taking literals and the other ticking
patterns well like I don't see why key
thought like couldn't take patterns I
don't see any reason it shouldn't take
patterns it should be fairly trivial I
can't think of a reason why I couldn't
off the top of my head
um I'm also not crazy about the name
because to me sort like sounds like
you know
oh I guess okay I think I'm starting to
understand the name it's saying sort
like this second argument exactly so the
documentation would say something like
sort you know
you know sort
of list
um
comma template or something
uh I shouldn't say pattern I should say
um
well okay whatever
uh sorts list in an order
that conforms to templates or something
like that
right could that um trailing blank be
optional should that always be implied
yeah I think we're saying it's implicit
okay
yeah
because you don't
if you're sorting it you don't want it
just removing elements that don't match
in the past exactly if it's a sort it's
a sort and it can't drop yeah right
I like this function this is a useful
function this is something where
because otherwise we're doing a sort by
with all kinds of weird criteria and so
on yeah I wrote that weird criteria like
four times before I made the function
repository entry
I was like this yeah
yeah all right let's keep going here
just for a few minutes
quiet
mostly a convenience function it's a
fairly common idiom of I want to quiet
all or some subset of messages and then
I want to do something if a message
occurs either to recapture messages and
issue them with a new head or to give
some sort of failure state
it's not anything that can't be
accomplished with quiet and check
together but it's a pretty common idiom
so
it may make some sense to combine it
into a single so I understand what it's
doing here it's just saying it's doing
the same thing as check but it is
quieting when it does your check yeah so
yeah
I agree that this is a useful thing yeah
the free argument form of check it's
always tedious because you almost always
want to wrap that with a quiet using the
same uh messages
a um related need that comes up a lot in
ild is to replace message heads
I don't know if this is quite the right
idiom for that in a general way but it
might be
what do you mean to replace master
shreds with the actual function being
used as opposed to where the message
came from correct yeah so it's pretty
common in at least the the initial
versions of ild functions to we're
calling other functions from top level
but we don't want those functions to
pass their own messages up we want to
capture them and reissue them we need to
we need a wrapper that just says uh
yeah yes
I I just linked a function in the
repository that does this
is this also defining or I guess
catching the message definitions when it
does is this um where you have power
Rick that would that take blank
I actually can't remember it was a while
ago when I did this okay I think I
probably did that
I think we should have something like
this I mean this is a
um however
I don't really understand the
relationship between this and confirms
and you know confirmed quiet and things
like this and we should look at that
in other words if you replace something
does it know
the source of the source or does it just
go with what was there on its face
did you understand what I'm saying yes
no if there is nested code somewhere
that was explicitly checking for that
power message it wouldn't actually see
that or or maybe it does I don't really
know I mean it's a question of whether
you know it's it's like a DBA you know
doing business as whatever you know do
you know what the actual underlying
function is
and under what circumstances do you kind
of drill down
yeah very much that
I think it's very complicated but
probably doable
right but I think this is the thing we
should we should take up in ild another
time
particularly when Christopher is around
and can talk about how it relates to
confirm and so on yeah well maybe take a
um okay but I think quiet check
particularly with its
uh the third argument to check
I see unless those messages
using that form of check with the three
arguments I almost always wrap that with
a quiet using that exact same list of
messages so I just have to repeat that
list of messages twice which is kind of
tedious
right because the things you're looking
for and you're handling so you don't
want to spew messages about them because
but now this thing about message groups
we have never properly handled that
that's part of the error handling
working discussion right
to deal with that
yes I don't know what the current status
of that is but we can maybe Loop that in
you're not talking near-term no I'm not
talking instantly I I don't even mean
intermediate term for what
the this message groupings
um the last time we've been talking
about it in the error handling
discussion well the last time we talked
about it the your opinion was that it
wasn't really a useful thing to expand
no it doesn't it doesn't it's not it's
not we needed error handling is the more
important by far
we need a different strategy for these
things and message groups is not it
I mean again we've talked about this a
zillion times we've talked about the
case where you want incredibly
Persnickety error handling where you
know if anything could possibly go wrong
kill it to you know hey if it's roughly
right I'll let it through type thing
am I making sense
yeah and that very much is error
handling and very little messaging I
agree
yeah well maybe you have an error
handling Summit and uh ild but check
seems fine it seems useful
and it goes along with other you know
quiet star functions
so this is right now that Rick brought
it up we should consider message replace
oh I agree I agree can we bring that
back to another meeting like this please
please do develop it a bit more and
bring it back here this is something I
need incessantly for ild Stuff fine and
copyright of what Nick may have
suggested I don't mean needed just for
first implementations no yeah fair
enough right yeah uh so this next one is
a variation on round that rather than
giving the you know an absolute value
you're rounding to we're giving a number
of significant digits
um you know the kind of common idiom of
round this value to four digits
um it's fairly popular in wfr one
possibility Danny and I and I think well
I hate the name yes we don't like a
decimal round as a standalone function
at least by that name but perhaps
there's some Merit to having a scaled
headdress in round to represent relative
error effectively relative number of
digits I I don't think it's 100 fits but
there is an argument
to be had that it is you know using that
is incomprehensible nobody will ever
understand it yeah well scaled may be
the wrong headdress yeah I understand
but well I mean what about using a list
does around yeah I was just going to say
n is already a precedent for accuracy I
know it's a hard to understand future
event
um
look I think about this thing about make
this a four significant figures thing
I I would just say that I mean even
without understanding that right with n
you can give it a a Singleton list so
you know round four being surround to
multiples of four and round list four
give me four digits
that's not hard to understand even if
the full generality of the two are you
know the Two element list is more
difficult to understand
we might want that though
yes I understand but what's this
this I'm proposing would be round pi to
four significant digits
because in N you can either give it a a
single element list which means
Precision just give the Precision you
don't mean List no you don't mean List
you mean a single element
s
i i i said Singleton list which is
exactly what I mean a list containing
one element
right you can also put a a Singleton for
there
it says it's an error
huh okay so what am I thinking of uh I
mean we could make this work but it
doesn't work right now I'd like to know
what you were looking at
I think he was looking off into space
and not at the screen
okay I I I I I I missed where that we
skipped okay all right around the end
um well okay well okay but so so what
happens if I say Pi of n of Pi comma
uh four comma ten
I don't understand what that does ten
comma four
I don't know what this is doing a
thousand pi
hmm
I don't understand this or so four
places
right so it's accuracy for
um so four digits after the decimal
point
and so make it um
six comma four
okay then it's going to limit on that
yeah yeah so it's the first whichever
comes first
and yes well it's going to limit on the
thing that is first constrains it yeah
yeah yeah and decimal round could
conceivably have a similar
yeah but round right now
does not have a digit count it has a
I mean what about something like digit
round
to some number of digits
which by the way would have to have an
accuracy precision type thing in it as
well we have to decide what the default
is
this is in some ways similar to decimal
form I think
no which is probably why it was called
decimal route
Maybe
yeah it's similar to this decimal form
of n comma but that is a print form
yeah that's the that's a big difference
but nonetheless the spec is very
similarly treated which is why decimal
round is not therefore that crazy a name
but it's a little bit it's an it's I
mean
but digit round doesn't seem crazy to me
because it's like round this thing to
four digits
is it clear that we don't want to use
round
with it yes because because I think
round look round takes
a second argument which is you know
nearest multiple of whatever okay sure I
just don't see a way to do this yeah
you're right you're right that one play
nice
and it really is a digit based version
of round which is because round is part
of the family of round floor ceiling
I mean I don't know and floor you know
that there isn't a lot of sense is there
yeah having a ceiling comma go ahead
right
digit ceiling doesn't make sense does it
no
so that that I I agree that this is a
good argument that put sticking this
into round is a mistake of yes and I
know what I was thinking if if you've
defined an N value with just a single
with just a single number it'll be
stored as the Two element list and
that's where I got it
so I'm not completely crazy I'm only 50
crazy
um
why doesn't digit ceiling make sense
it does
I don't think it would be commonly used
but here we have the same problem with
that second argument
so so so what what what what you wanted
to do you'd want it to frown to the
it would basically just round up the
last digit to whatever precision
yes yes
um and down so yeah it's the usual
problem with fives
but otherwise
but I think digit round is somewhat
useful I think it's a
yeah I think the the I think the other
reason not to stick this in in round is
that you know round has you know
function expand rules and
differentiation rules because you know
you can make sense yeah I'm convinced uh
you you guys were right
don't put it in round I might just
suggest digits around
so you're rounding to some number of
digits yeah it's not crazy
none of our digit functions currently
are plural
but what are the digit functions
that isn't
a digit count digit sum
digit round sounds cleaner
okay
without the S okay yeah and put a pin in
digit floor and ceiling for now and
think about the more yeah the the
they're one of these things that in
another Century people like much more
obscure the use cases I think
right
okay all right we should probably wrap
up here
um this has been
good uh
and um
uh fine
thanks to folks on the live stream thank
you people here see you all soon
thanks everyone bye